it's official xbox's 7.5 billion dollar
acquisition of bethesda has gone through
making it one of the
biggest deals in gaming history but what
does it all mean
and what does that mean for the future
of bethesda games are they going to be
xbox exclusives
well joining me to talk about what all
of this means we've got playstation pro
tomorrow hussein
i imagine pete hines but like gold homer
[Music]
or todd howard with all the rings and
xbox expert jordan remay what's up
uh you might notice that the console
crew each week we talk about the biggest
stories in console gaming so join us
every friday but obviously this news is
so big we had to jump on it
so you get two little bonus episodes
this week but let's get into it
what does the future mean for xbox and
bethesda
like i mentioned up top the biggest
question that has come out of this
acquisition is what does this mean
for the future of bethesda studios in
particular are there games
going it to be xbox exclusive so a quick
reminder of the games and franchises
that are going to be going over to the
xbox
to fall under the xbox first party
umbrella i should say
you've got arcane tango machine games
you have obviously bethesda game studios
they are adding eight new studios
bringing
xbox's total up to over 20 which is a
great move for them
uh games like fallout elder scrolls star
field
potentially stuff in the future so you
know that indiana jones game that
machine works are
working on um it's very interesting
because
pete hines from bethesda as well as phil
spencer from xbox have both commented
and they're keeping cards very close to
the chest but both of them have kind of
left little breadcrumbs about what the
future holds
so tam do you want to read uh this
section from pete hines statement
um right here so pete hines statement
um classic silver tongue pete hines he
said
first let me say that we're not making
any landmark announcements or changes
right now
as we've all shared the expectation is
that bethesda softworks and our studios
will continue as we have in the past
just with more support and resources
than we've ever had before
obviously game pass has been an
important initiative for xbox
and we'll be working on putting even
more of our games
into game pass than ever before beyond
that
stay tuned we're just getting started
together
so this is great so it's great it
doesn't really say a lot but the one
thing that i did notice that he was
saying is
game pass and game pass is obviously the
big push that xbox has
um and they brought it up a lot in that
conversation with you know pete todd
howard and phil spencer from last
year so my i mean
jordan what are you reading from this
statement from pete when he's mentioning
game pass all the time
i mean game pass is kind of xbox's big
exclusive right now they don't have
the first party quality that playstation
nintendo kind of have going for them
at the moment so more games coming to
game pass is good
for xbox and just reading it though i
i understand acquisitions are messy like
i was one of those people who
apparently just doesn't understand how
acquisitions work and thought for the
longest time that this whole bethesda
zenimax thing had already gone
through and they were already xbox
studios all this time
apparently not um and i i just
want something anything more
definitive about how
all of this is working going forward
which i'm sure we'll get at some point
but like well you might
for a bit not for a bit but like
something anything other like what what
where did they use earlier it's like
some
games like a few games or whatever i'm
like i i
i need anything like just
just say like oh by the way this one
game that a bethesda studio is working
on
not going to be an xbox exclusive i'm
like cool
one definitive we have something on the
playing field to like mark off as
this isn't it you can't use a game
that's already been announced like death
loop or something like that that doesn't
count
i was gonna say well death loop and
ghost wide tokyo both have elements of
playstation exclusivity at least for
about a year i believe it is
so big phil's uh big phil spencer's
statement
um the deck of the xbox y post was the
thing that really grabbed me which was
the publisher of iconic gaming
franchises
will expand xbox's diverse portfolio on
xbox game pass
and then you know there are some there's
some little quotes that he said you know
so we're working together to deliver
so this is where it's interesting he
says deliver more great games
to everyone and then
follows up with what does that mean
anything this is the next step in
building an industry-leading first party
studios team a commitment we have to our
xbox community with the addition of the
bethesda creative teams
gamers should know that xbox consoles pc
and game pass will be the best place to
experience new bethesda games
including some new titles in the future
that will be exclusive to xbox and pc
players so i
have a theory because there have been
all of these rumblings that there are
unannounced xbox projects in the works
that are going to launch this year
something from bethesda is going to be
an
xbox exclusive later this year and i
guarantee and i wonder if it will
be one i wonder if it's if if those two
things are going to combine
and that's what it's going to be so but
i think there's a there's a new bethesda
game coming out
that will be exclusive to xbox and pc
oh uh-huh that's interesting i mean if
it's just
like something along like grounded like
uh
level i could possibly see that like
we're not getting something like on par
with like
death loop exclusive i think to xbox by
the end of the year they dropped
it they dropped dishonored three and
make that an xbox exclusive then
people would riot in the streets
i would i mean i would be happy that the
dishonored 3 has appeared
more than anything um as it stands we
know that they have
indiana jones in production potentially
a wolfenstein i don't think they've ever
officially announced
i don't think they've officially
announced it but like there's rumblings
about it
and starfield and elder scrolls
i as it stands i struggle to see
any of those games being
exclusive to xbox perhaps um certainly
not i don't know maybe not starfield and
elder scrolls
given the scale of them and microsoft
wants to make money i feel like jordan's
right in that
there will be something smaller um and
maybe
indiana jones is small enough to to be
kind of that kind of
uh i don't know it's a licensed game i
don't think
the problem is it's it's a licensed game
unless the the kind of terms of that
were already pre-established like
let's not forget spider-man is a
licensed game
and sony absolutely dummy how about lucy
um
well in the same way and obviously if
microsoft wants something of that
of that kind of elk or for themselves
who can go toe-to-toe with spider-man if
not
indiana jones i can't believe you said
that with the
stream i don't even believe it i don't
even believe it but what i'm saying is
like
it there is there is some sort of
establish not precedent but like
framework for them to work on they could
have a similar kind of
license agreement but i i feel like
going forward
now the focus is very much both for the
company
and for their messaging it's going to be
on
we're putting this stuff on game pass so
i think we're going to get a drip feed
of bethesda titles being added to game
pass
while they figure out the messaging on
what's exclusive what isn't exclusive
another thing i wanted to discuss is the
phrasing um
xbox consoles pc and game pass will be
the best place to experience
new bethesda games so i do wonder if
that is
maybe teasing at the games that are
going to be coming
potentially to other platforms will have
bonuses whether that's
you know early dlc or extra items that
you can get
um specifically on xbox and pc
because of that licensing deal not
licensing deal because of that
relationship because that acquisition
yeah i think i think the the easy
grab is dlc right yeah but i think there
might be something in
even given early access to to
game pass subscribers in the same way
that ea does with their kind of games
on origin and stuff like that you know
you can if you subscribe to ea service
you get
titanfall 2 a week early or whatever it
may be whatever it was back then or fifa
or whatever it may be
um so i think that's a good way of doing
it um
but i think that more likely is you get
the dlc super uh early or
early-ish and then you get exclusive dlc
and content and that kind of stuff and
they'll just pump it through full of
extra value
um on their own services which makes a
lot of sense
yeah i mean they can also like if xbox
really wants to be
cheeky about it and who knows how far
they want to go they can
announce something like here's a new
game coming from machine works
and it's gonna cost i don't know
seventy dollars on ps5 and it's gonna be
free
on xbox and the free will have like a
little asterisk or something it's like
if you have
game pass in this game is no extra
charge
but it's going to be 70 if you want to
play it on
playstation 5 which is like a kind of
underhanded thing to do but i'm like
they could do something like that i mean
honestly
i i would be very very surprised that
they didn't do that because that is such
a win for them and it's you know
i think as well the thing with game pass
is that it's a fantastic service but
games rotate in and out and so if you do
have this
stable of bethesda games that are always
going to be there and like you know like
you're a bethesda fan like you love
fallout you love elder scrolls
that's going to be a no-brainer and so
i'm very very interested to see
how that comes but i think the next role
not roller coaster but i think the next
um thing they have to overcome is the
messaging regarding exclusivity because
not everyone has an xbox you know
where does that leave playstation gamers
because at the same time
you can have all this messaging that
says we want you know we're doing right
we want to do right by our community we
want to do right by our fans
but you are potentially leaving a lot of
them stranded
on a different platform so
but uh so that's you know they're gonna
so the final bit in phil spencer's thing
is we have more to share about what's
next for our teams later this year
in the meantime to properly celebrate
this special moment we are bringing
additional bethesda games onto game pass
later this week
uh no mention of the potential
rumored xbox bethesda event that has
been flying around
what you know means it's absolutely
gonna happen because whatever we talk
about just
happened it gets announced immediately
when we're editing this
so yeah you've you've confirmed it lucy
thank you
it's probably happening right now and
we're just not aware of it
wow this one in the three could you
imagine
if we get to something today so i mean i
think i think it's a very interesting
acquisition
and obviously i'm we're all fortunate
enough here to
have xboxes play game pass um but if
you're a playstation gamer and you know
this news has come to you especially the
confirmation that some stuff will be
exclusive to xbox and pc
let us know what you're thinking right
now because it's
gotta kind of sting i suppose so let us
know um in the comments below and we'll
read out some answers on console crew
this week which is gonna be on friday so
make sure to check back youtube.com
gamespot to watch and watch our
follow-up and hopefully maybe there'll
have been that event
but anyway thanks for watching i knew
this was going to happen i knew this was
going to happen when they released that
fallout 3 paul for playstation 3 and it
sucked
but hey skyrim on playstation sucked as
well so
just bethesda please
you